June is LGBTQ Pride Month, marked by marches and commemorations to celebrate LGBTQ culture and advocate for the rights of lesbian, gay, bisexual, transgender, and queer people in the U.S. and around the world. This year, President Biden marked the occasion with an official proclamation that touted progress on issues such as marriage and workplace equality. But it also called out areas where LGBT rights are being threatened, including in dozens of states where legislators have introduced bills this year targeting transgender youth. The focus of LGBTQ activism has evolved over the years with the issues and political pressures of the day, from the HIV-AIDS crisis in the 1980s to the militaries Don't Ask Don't Tell Rule in the 1990s, to the fight for marriage equality in the early 2000s, and the focus on transgender rights today.
六月是LGBTQ骄傲月，通过游行和纪念活动来庆祝LGBTQ文化，并为美国乃至全球的女同性恋者、男同性恋者、双性恋者、跨性别者和酷儿群体的权利进行倡导。今年，拜登总统发表了一份官方公告，以此纪念这一时刻，并称赞了在婚姻和平等就业等问题上取得的进展。但公告也指出了LGBT权利受到威胁的领域，包括今年有数十个州的立法者提出了针对跨性别青少年的法案。多年来，LGBTQ行动主义的焦点随着当下的议题和政治压力而演变，从20世纪80年代的艾滋病危机，到20世纪90年代军队的“不问不说”政策，再到21世纪初对婚姻平权的争取，以及今天对跨性别权利的关注。
How has psychological research reflected and responded to these changes? How has it contributed to the public discussion of prejudice and discrimination against sexual minorities? When has it helped and when has it hindered the drive toward equality for LGBTQ people, especially in the United States? What role has it played in moving the needle in the fight for LGBTQ rights, especially in our courts? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Peter Haggerty, a professor of psychology at the Open. University in the United Kingdom, where he studies the history of sexuality and gender and psychology.
心理学研究如何反映并回应了这些变化？它如何为关于针对性少数群体的偏见和歧视的公众讨论做出贡献？它在何时帮助了，又在何时阻碍了LGBTQ群体争取平权的进程，特别是在美国？它在推动LGBTQ权利斗争（尤其是在我们的法庭上）方面发挥了什么作用？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是英国开放大学的心理学教授彼得·哈格蒂博士，他在那里研究性、性别和心理学的历史。
His 2018 book, A Recent History of Lesbian and Gay Psychology, from Homophobia to LGBT, traces the psychological research on these issues since the 1970s. He was also guest editor of a special issue of APA's journal American Psychologist, entitled 50 Years Since Stonewall, The Science and Politics of Sexual Orientation and Gender Diversity. In addition to his work in the history of psychology, He conducts experimental research in areas including auditory Gaydar and how beliefs about the biological basis of sexual orientation influence prejudice and discrimination.
他2018年的著作《女同性恋和男同性恋心理学简史：从恐同到LGBT》追溯了自20世纪70年代以来关于这些议题的心理学研究。他还是美国心理学会期刊《美国心理学家》特刊的客座编辑，该特刊题为《石墙事件50周年：性取向和性别多样性的科学与政治》。除了在心理学史方面的工作外，他还进行实验研究，领域包括听觉“同志雷达”（Gaydar），以及关于性取向生物学基础的信念如何影响偏见和歧视。
Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Hegarty. Thank you, Kim. It's an honor to be here. So you're a historian of psychology as well as a psychologist, so let's start with some history. You begin your book in the 1970s just before the Stonewall uprising in New York, which is considered to be the beginning of the modern LGBTQ rights movement. Was it also a turning point in how the field of psychology regarded sexual minorities? It was, and there was a strategic decision on my part to start in that time period.
感谢您今天加入我们，哈格蒂博士。谢谢你，金。很荣幸能来到这里。您既是心理学史学家，也是心理学家，所以让我们从历史开始谈起。您的书从20世纪70年代开始，就在纽约石墙骚乱之前，这被认为是现代LGBTQ权利运动的开端。这也是心理学领域看待性少数群体方式的一个转折点吗？确实如此，我当时做出了一个战略性的决定，从那个时期开始写起。
And that was because very often when I read histories about the history of sexuality and psychology, and the most of which we had access, they very often ended in that period. So very often you see a broad brush stroke starting with Freud, proceeding through Kinsey studies, maybe mentioning Evelyn Hooker and her work in the 1950s, and it often ends up in something like the Stonewall uprising, and then the 1973 decision by the American Psychiatric Association to begin to depathologize homosexuality. And that framework of thinking, where the past ends and the present begins somewhere around the mid-1970s, is not something that's unique to this area of psychology.
这是因为，当我阅读关于性与心理学历史的著作时（我们能接触到的大多数著作），它们往往在那个时期就结束了。所以你经常看到一种大而化之的叙述，从弗洛伊德开始，经过金赛的研究，也许会提到伊芙琳·胡克和她在20世纪50年代的工作，然后往往以石墙骚乱之类的事件，以及1973年美国精神医学学会开始将同性恋去病理化的决定作为结尾。这种认为过去在20世纪70年代中期左右结束、现在从那里开始的思维框架，在心理学的这个领域并非独有。
Very often, that's something that we kind of encounter as history audience of psychology. So I think there is a number of us who were sort of thinking, well, we clearly don't live in the 1970s anymore. And when we teach the history of psychology to our students, like the 1970s just is a very, very far away period. So things need to be massively updated. So one of the reasons why I chose that timeframe was to try to make a contribution to a much larger movement in the history of psychology to think about what has the reason. history of psychology being what's been happening in more recent decades and sort of changed the narrative focus of how we do things. Was that a period in which things changed in psychology?
我们作为心理学历史的受众，经常会遇到这种情况。所以我认为我们中有不少人当时在想，好吧，我们显然不再生活在20世纪70年代了。当我们向学生教授心理学史时，20世纪70年代是一个非常、非常遥远的时期。所以事情需要进行大规模的更新。我选择那个时间框架的原因之一，是试图为心理学史中一个更宏大的运动做出贡献，去思考心理学的近期历史是什么，近几十年来发生了什么，并改变我们做事方式的叙事焦点。那是一个心理学发生变化的时期吗？
Absolutely. And that was a period, a really interesting period of incredible change where issues about social justice, issues about inequality came to the fore much more than they had done. Exploded in many ways because psychology wasn't able to keep a culture that was separate from the many social movements that were characterising the American political scene at this point in time, not least, of course, the civil rights movements and the protests against the Vietnam War. And looking back at that period, you can see that it is a time where there is, it's also the period where people start to talk about generation gaps.
绝对是。那是一个非常有趣的时期，发生了令人难以置信的变化，关于社会正义、关于不平等的议题比以往任何时候都更加突出。在许多方面爆发了，因为心理学无法保持一种与当时美国政治舞台上许多社会运动相脱离的文化，尤其是民权运动和反越战抗议。回顾那个时期，你可以看到这是一个人们开始谈论“代沟”的时期。
That's a term that's used for the first time, if I understand it correctly, in the 1960s, where there seems to be a very different consciousness between younger and older people and a difference about what psychology should do, what it should be doing, what its accountability is around issues around chronic injustice, and whether it is possible to kind of remain on the fence about those kinds of things. So one thing that happens in that context, which is sort of less well known, and I certainly didn't know about it for a long time, is that in addition to having activist protests at the meetings of the American Psychiatric Association in the early 1970s, there was one at the American Psychological Association in 1973 on a very similar model.
如果我理解得没错，这是20世纪60年代第一次使用的术语，当时年轻人和老年人之间似乎存在着非常不同的意识，对于心理学应该做什么、应该做什么、它在慢性不公正问题上的责任是什么，以及是否有可能在这些事情上保持中立，存在着分歧。因此，在这种背景下发生的一件事（不太为人所知，我肯定很长一段时间都不知道）是，除了20世纪70年代初在美国精神医学学会会议上的激进抗议外，1973年在美国心理学会也发生了一次类似的抗议。
And shortly after that, what happens is there's a committee for lesbian and gay concerns, I believe it's called, and it becomes part of the Board for Social and Ethical Responsibility in Psychology, which is something that only existed for, a few years and was set up by Kenneth Clark and some other people because of these questions about what is psychology doing about gender injustice and racial injustice. So that's a little bit where the story starts to be sure. And I'm kind of curious in there about, we often tell the story about psychiatry, which of course is so important because psychiatry held this power over the diagnosis, the diagnosis statistical manual. But it is funny that psychologists itself included, you know, so often told that story about psychiatry.
在那之后不久，发生的事情是成立了一个委员会，我相信它被称为女同性恋和男同性恋关注委员会，它成为了心理学社会和道德责任委员会的一部分，该委员会只存在了几年，是由肯尼斯·克拉克和其他一些人因为这些关于心理学在性别不公正和种族不公正方面正在做什么的问题而设立的。所以故事就是从这里开始的。我很好奇，我们经常讲述关于精神病学的故事，这当然非常重要，因为精神病学掌握着诊断权，即《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》。但奇怪的是，心理学本身（包括我们自己）竟然如此频繁地讲述关于精神病学的故事。
I never told the story about psychology itself. That's a good point, and I did want to talk about that a little bit. Some of our listeners might not really be aware of how psychiatry was compelled to remove homosexuality from the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders, which is pretty much the arbiter of what constitutes a mental illness or a mental disorder among all behavioral health practitioners. Can you talk a little bit more about how that happened with psychiatry, which, yes, was very distinctive, but then psychology, which followed a couple of years later? Yeah, absolutely. So it's a good question to ask about that, that DSM go a little bit further back in its history, maybe.
我从来没有讲述过关于心理学本身的故事。这是一个很好的观点，我确实想稍微谈谈这一点。我们的一些听众可能并不真正了解精神病学是如何被迫将同性恋从《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中删除的，该手册几乎是所有行为健康从业者判定什么是精神疾病或精神障碍的仲裁者。你能多谈谈精神病学是如何发生这种情况的吗？是的，这非常独特，但心理学在几年后也紧随其后？是的，绝对可以。问关于DSM的问题是一个很好的切入点，也许可以追溯到更早的历史。
You know, the first codes are from the early 1950s, and they were written from a blueprint for the codes for including or excluding soldiers in the American Armed Forces in World War II. And it was in that context where the armed forces began to inquire. about men's homosexuality and use that as ground for excluding them from the military. Right, because they were thought to be security risks as a result. Well, I think in World War II, they were also thought to be a risk more in terms of mental health. Would they be fit for combat or would they end up being sort of a drain on the Army's resources? I think that was also a sort of concern. So it was kind of, that's why it sort of within psychiatry.
你知道，第一版手册源于20世纪50年代初，它们是根据二战期间美国武装部队征兵或排除士兵的准则蓝图编写的。正是在这种背景下，武装部队开始调查男性的同性恋情况，并以此作为将他们排除在军队之外的理由。对，因为他们被认为因此而存在安全风险。嗯，我认为在二战中，他们也被认为在心理健康方面存在更大的风险。他们是否适合战斗，或者他们最终是否会成为军队资源的消耗？我认为这也是一种担忧。所以这就是为什么它存在于精神病学内部。
But you're right, that rationale did emerge certainly later on to be sure to justify that policy. So the DSM was also initially a very psychoanalytic document, but that was coming under question in the 1970s. And the psychoanalytic basis for calling a lot of things a mental disorder was quite insecure. And maybe homosexuality was the very best example of that. And activists such as Barbara Gittings and Frank Kameney began to target. the APA and the DSM strategically towards the very end of the 1960s and to articulate it as a problem. They're writing is very interesting and are ahead of some of the things that are happening in psychology at the time. So that started off with a process of direct action and protesting and
但你是对的，那种理由确实在后来出现，以证明该政策的合理性。所以DSM最初也是一份非常精神分析的文件，但这在20世纪70年代受到了质疑。将许多事物称为精神障碍的精神分析基础相当不稳固。也许同性恋就是最好的例子。像芭芭拉·吉廷斯和弗兰克·卡梅尼这样的活动家开始在20世纪60年代末战略性地针对美国精神医学学会和DSM，并将其阐述为一个问题。他们的写作非常有趣，领先于当时心理学界正在发生的一些事情。所以这始于直接行动、抗议和
disrupting meetings and using those kinds of tactics which were common to various rights movements at the time. And then there were also some politics where there were some sympathetic psychiatrists. There was probably a little bit of a silent minority of psychiatrists who were very unhappy about this diagnosis, actually. And some surveys at the time actually suggest that that's the case. And so there was some politics behind the scene that then led some of those actors to actually speak at an APA conference. And that initiated a vote of members as to whether homosexuality should remain a mental illness or not. And I think that vote was not quite a two-thirds, one-third majority.
扰乱会议，并使用当时各种权利运动所共有的那些策略。然后还有一些政治因素，有一些富有同情心的精神科医生。实际上，当时可能有一小部分沉默的精神科医生对这种诊断非常不满。当时的一些调查实际上表明了这一点。因此，幕后有一些政治活动，随后促使其中一些参与者在美国精神医学学会的会议上发言。这引发了成员投票，决定同性恋是否应该继续被视为一种精神疾病。我认为那次投票的比例并非完全是三分之二对三分之一。
It was a bit closer than that. And then the next version of the DSM was published in about 1980. And even still, like, it was far from complete. If we just think about sexual orientation for a moment, because what was sort of retained there was this idea of what became known as ego-distonic homosexuality. So if you were gay and you wanted a psychiatrist to try and cure you, what you might now call conversion therapy or sexual orientation change efforts, that was still legitimate in psychiatry,
比那要接近一些。然后下一版DSM大约在1980年出版。即便如此，它也远未完成。如果我们暂时只考虑性取向，因为那里保留了一种后来被称为“自我不协调同性恋”的概念。所以如果你是同性恋，并且你想让精神科医生尝试治愈你（你现在可能称之为转化疗法或性取向改变努力），这在精神病学中仍然是合法的，
and that didn't go away until the 90s. Now, you mentioned that the DSM is kind of the arbiter of mental health, and that's absolutely right. It's extremely powerful, but there's always sort of been two systems in modern psychiatry, I mean, from World War II on. The other one is the ICD, the international classification of diseases,
这种情况直到90年代才消失。现在，你提到DSM是心理健康的仲裁者，这绝对正确。它极其强大，但从二战开始，现代精神病学中一直存在着两个系统。另一个是ICD，即国际疾病分类，
which covers physical health and mental health. And it didn't remove homosexuality until the very early 90s, and that's the event that is celebrated by, Ida Hobbes Day in May. So I'm just curious, I mean, for so many years, psychology and psychiatry viewed homosexuality as a mental illness. Was there really any actual scientific evidence for such thinking? That's a really good question. I mean, one counted the scientific evidence then, and what counted the scientific evidence now is not the same thing.
它涵盖了身体健康和心理健康。直到90年代初它才删除了同性恋，这一事件在5月被“国际不再恐同日”所庆祝。所以我很好奇，多年来，心理学和精神病学一直将同性恋视为一种精神疾病。这种想法真的有任何实际的科学证据吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我的意思是，当时算作科学证据的东西，和现在算作科学证据的东西是不一样的。
So I think what happened to be charitable to that is that they were self-fulfilling prophecies. people who were gay or lesbian, people who are queer, people who were troubled by their sense of self might reach out to a mental health professional for help. They might present as wanting this aspect of themselves to go away because that was how they could imagine living a better life. And so that definitely happened to be sure. But I think evidence that people brought to bear to challenge that consensus is really quite interesting at that period. You know, two people that do often stand out in that in the US context are Alfred Kinsey and Evelyn Hooker. One of the things Kinsey was was this self-fulfilling prophecy. And he thought, well, there are these people for whom
所以我认为，宽容地看，发生的事情是它们成为了自我实现的预言。那些是同性恋或女同性恋的人，那些是酷儿的人，那些对自己的自我感感到困扰的人，可能会向心理健康专业人士寻求帮助。他们可能会表现出希望自己身上的这一方面消失，因为那是他们能想象到的过上更好生活的方式。所以这种情况肯定发生过。但我认为人们用来挑战这种共识的证据在那个时期确实非常有趣。你知道，在美国背景下，经常脱颖而出的两个人是阿尔弗雷德·金赛和伊芙琳·胡克。金赛所做的事情之一就是这种自我实现的预言。他想，好吧，有这样一些人，对他们来说
homosexuality is part of their life. And, you know, Kinsey was bisexual-oriented himself. And he thought, if I go outside of these cities and I go outside of these little tiny little secret gay enclaves, then I'm going to find these people who are very different from each other. And it's going to challenge this stereotype about what they're going to. the signs of homosexuality are, which were things like gender inversion or artistic interests for men or things like that. And so that's very much what the Kinsey studies are all about and why Kinsey samples so widely and why he kind of gets in his car and travels to every state. And, you know, studies people who have no understanding of homosexual culture, but might be practicing homosexuality
同性恋是他们生活的一部分。而且，你知道，金赛本人就是双性恋倾向。他想，如果我走出这些城市，走出这些小小的秘密同性恋聚居区，那么我就会发现这些人彼此之间非常不同。这将挑战关于同性恋标志是什么的刻板印象，比如男性的性别倒错或艺术兴趣之类的东西。所以这就是金赛研究的全部内容，也是为什么金赛的样本如此广泛，为什么他会开车去每个州。而且，你知道，研究那些对同性恋文化毫无了解，但可能在性生活中实践同性恋的人。
in their sex lives. And indeed, that's what he finds. So that was sort of Kinsey. And he really didn't like Freud or any of these kinds of ideas that there was a distinctions. to homosexual personality. And Evelyn Hooker was an experimental psychologist who went at this in a very different kind of way. I think in the post-war period between World War II and the Stonewall uprising for the sake of some bookends, there was a lot of discontent in psychology about the psychiatric basis of mental health care because it was considered to be quite unformed. And psychologists developed a lot of scientific ways of thinking, many of which had the effect of sort of reining that in, one of which, of course, was the language of talking about the kind
确实，他就是这样发现的。所以这就是金赛。他真的不喜欢弗洛伊德或任何认为同性恋人格存在区别的想法。而伊芙琳·胡克是一位实验心理学家，她以一种非常不同的方式处理这个问题。我认为在二战和石墙骚乱之间的战后时期，为了书的结构，心理学界对精神卫生保健的精神病学基础有很多不满，因为它被认为相当不成熟。心理学家发展了许多科学的思维方式，其中许多产生了某种程度上限制这种做法的效果，其中之一当然是谈论测试的效度和信度的语言，这在那个时期得到了更多的发展，通常像罗夏测试就是目标。罗夏测试也是胡克所做的对照实验的目标，她找来男同性恋者和异性恋者，给他们都做了罗夏测试，发现没有区别。现在，我其实并不认为这是她所做的事情中最有趣的部分。我真的认为那是其中最枯燥、最无聊的部分。我认为她所做的绝对令人惊叹的事情是，她和布鲁诺·克洛普弗是朋友，当时他是美国的罗夏测试大师之一。他们两人最终都在同一时期在加州大学洛杉矶分校任教。她把测试结果交给克洛普弗进行分析。
of validity and reliability of tests that got much more developed in that period, and often things like the Rorschark test, where the target of that. And the Rorschach test was the target of a controlled experiment that Hooker did as well, where she took gay and straight men, gave them all Rorschart test and found that there was no difference. Now, I kind of don't think that's actually the interesting thing about what she did at all. I really think that's the most dull and boring thing. I think what she did that was absolutely amazing was she was friends with a guy called Bruno Klopfer, who at the time was sort of the Rorschach guru or one of the Rorschach gurus in the US. And they both ended up teaching in UCLA around the same time. And she gave the test results to Klopfer to analyze.
他读了之后说，天哪，你知道，如果我不知道这个家伙是同性恋，那个家伙是异性恋，罗夏测试的档案里没有任何东西能让我判断出来。我认为这之所以如此聪明，首先是因为意识到，我认为布鲁诺·克洛普弗是那项研究中真正的参与者。
And he read them and he said, oh my God, you know, like, if I hadn't known that this guy was gay and this guy was straight, there's nothing in the Roarsartre profile that I could have done to do that. And I think what was so smart about that was, first of all, realizing that by, I think Bruno Clouffer is the real study participant
研究中有三位专家，但我认为克洛普弗因为他的地位可能是最重要的。我认为胡克所做的是，她采用了那种一直以来审视同性恋者并假设同性恋者和异性恋者之间存在差异的科学视角，
in that study. There was three experts, but I think Clouffer was probably the most important because of his status. And I think what Hooker did is she took that sort of scientific lens that had always been sort of looking at gay people and assuming there was a difference between gay and straight people
并利用这种差异（无论是真实的还是所谓的）来建立一种缺陷模型，建立一种诊断，并建立一个心理健康故事。她所做的是，她审视了同性恋，并将其扭转了过来。她将其向上应用于那种会解释这些罗夏测试的专家推理形式。当她这样做时，整个系统就崩溃了。所以我总是看着这一点，我想，
and using that difference, whether it was real or purported, to kind of build a deficit model and build a diagnosis and build a mental health story. And what she did, she kind of looked at gay as and turned it around. She turned it upwards on the form of expert reasoning that would interpret these raw sharks. And when it did, the whole system kind of crushed. So I always look at that and I think,
我总是认为胡克真正出色之处不在于她出去发现两组之间没有区别。我认为那很棒。但我认为她利用布鲁诺·克洛普弗和那项研究的方式相当出色。最后，她拍了一部关于她生活的电影。我想实际上可能是美国心理学会在她去世前制作的，她死于20世纪90年代。她在电影中对后来20世纪70年代事件的反思真的非常有趣，因为她当时……当我看到所有这些在美国精神医学学会发生的抗议活动时，她说，我最初非常担心，你知道。我想这很糟糕，你知道，我想这会破坏这些女同性恋和男同性恋运动的声誉。但后来她说，不，然后我意识到，这就是将要创造变革的东西。所以我认为思考这一点非常迷人，因为我认为这经常发生在历史上。一个人可能在某个时间点领先于时代，但在另一个时间点，其他人领先于时代，你知道吗？
I always think what was really brilliant about Hooker was not that she went out and found no difference between two groups. I think that's great. But I think it's the fact that the way she enjoyed Bruno Cloughford and that research is quite brilliant. And then lastly, she made a film about her life. I think actually the APA might have made it before she died and she died in the 1990s. And her reflections in that film about the events later on in the 1970s are really very interesting because she kind of When I saw all these protests happening at the American Psychiatric Association, she's like, I was initially quite worried, you know. I thought this was bad, you know, I thought this is going to blow the respectability of these lesbian and gay movements. But then she said, no, then I realized, like, this is what's going to create the change. So I think it's just kind of fascinating to sort of think about this because I think this is what often happens in history. One might be kind of ahead of the times at one point in time, but then at another point of time, other people are ahead of the times, you know?
我认为她在成熟的反思中有一种可爱之处，即她何时领先于时代，以及当她可以退后一步说，哦，我以为那是错的。但实际上，不，不，不，那些人在那个时候对如何将所有这些事情结合在一起有正确的想法。他们创造了变革。我无法做到这一点。那么，性别歧视在心理学家和其他心理健康专业人士长期看待LGBT群体的方式中发挥了什么作用？今天它又发挥了什么作用？可能作用相当大。我不确定总的来说这是一个好主意
And I think there's something lovely in her kind of mature reflection on that of when she was ahead of the times and maybe when she could stand back and say, oh, I thought that was wrong. But actually, no, no, no, those people had the right idea about how to put all those things together at that point. They created the change. I couldn't have done that. So what role has sexism played in the way that psychologists and other mental health professionals viewed LGBT people over time? And what role is it playing even today? probably quite a large one. I'm not sure it's always a good idea in general
去思考性别歧视、异性恋霸权和种族主义必然是完全独立的种类，因为它们往往与彼此紧密相连。我的意思是，我认为心理健康必须始终以一种非常模糊的方式来定义什么是心理健康的人。这是一个极其模糊的问题。我甚至不知道那个问题的答案。
to think about sexism and heterosexism and racism as necessarily being completely separate kinds of things as they're often very, very bound up with each other. I mean, I think what mental health has to do always is sort of specify in a really vague way what it means to be a mentally healthy person. And that's an incredibly fuzzy question. I don't even know the answer to that question.
关于我自己，有时我必须说，我并不是在开玩笑。我诚实地、认真地有时真的不知道。但我认为以一种人文主义的方式来做心理健康，让某人能够成为完整的自我，然后将其编纂成文，写出那些程序应该是什么或那些类别应该是什么，而不在此同时划定一个关于什么是心理健康的人的规范，是非常困难的。所以我将把这从性别转向种族。但在那个你如此友好地提到的《美国心理学家》特刊中有一篇论文。它是关于一个名为Eramint中心的档案历史，该中心是由男同性恋和女同性恋者在20世纪70年代初在费城建立的。
about myself on some days, I have to say, and I mean, I'm not saying that facetiously. I honestly, seriously don't know that sometimes. But I think it's very difficult to do mental health in a humanistic way to sort of enable somebody to be their full selves and then to sort of codify that and to write out what those procedures should be or what those categories should be, without at the same time then drawing a norm about what would must be to be a mentally health person. So I'm going to turn this kind of away from gender and towards race a little bit. But just there is a paper in that American psychologist special issue, which you mentioned so nicely. And it's an archival history of something called the Eramint Center, which was set up in Philadelphia by gay and lesbian people in the early 1970s.
他们想做肯定性的咨询。所以他们从卡尔·罗杰斯那里抓住了这种想法，即人们需要被倾听，没有评判，带着同情。他们将此建立在他们自己亲身经历的基础上，你知道，并认为这是进行这种人文主义干预的更好基础，而不是心理学给出的模型。我认为作为一个基于社区的项目，解决异性恋霸权，解决真正的心理健康需求，
And they wanted to do affirmative counseling. And so they grasped this kind of idea from Carl Rogers that, you know, people needed to be listened to without judgment, with sympathy. And they grounded this in their own lived experiences, you know, and thought this was a better basis for doing this kind of humanistic intervention than the models that had been given by psychology. And I think as a community-based project, you know, addressing heterosexualism, addressing real mental health needs,
那在1970年是一个非常好的起点，拒绝那些东西并采用这种做法非常有意义。但随着故事的发展，你可以看到这种个人经验也有局限性，随着中心开始接触非白人、开始接触年轻一代、开始接触跨性别者、开始接触从海外来到美国的人，这些局限性在故事中变得非常明显。它确实告诉了我们一点关于为什么在不设定规范的情况下定义什么是心理健康是如此具有挑战性的故事，你知道吗？我认为这在做这件事时总是一种风险。我没有任何心理健康培训，我应该说。没有人应该把任何人的心理健康托付给我。那是个坏主意。过去发生过这种情况。结果并不好。好吧，让我们换个话题。
that was a very good starting point in 1970, rejecting those things and going with that made a lot of sense. But as the story develops, what you can see is there was also limits to that personal experience and they became very apparent in the story as the centre began to engage with people who were not white, as it began to engage with a younger generation of people, as it began to engage with transgender people, it began to engage with people who were coming into the USA for overseas. And it does tell us a little bit of a story about why it's so challenging
转向谈论20世纪80年代开始的艾滋病流行，那如何改变了研究人员提出的问题？是的，我认为在新冠疫情期间问这个问题非常及时。当然。我想我们稍后也可能会考虑这种关系。所以，是的，我寻找了心理学家在关于艾滋病方面写了什么，以及何时写的。我认为在20世纪80年代中期，这方面发生了真正的巨变。所以当总统委员会报告出来时，美国国家科学院发布了一份报告。在20世纪80年代早期，你可以在科学界看到发生的事情是，有一种非常强烈的方法，即艾滋病将首先通过生物学模型来解决。通过生物学模型，
to specify what mental health is without setting a norm, you know? And I think that that's always a risk in doing it. I don't have any mental health training, I should say. Nobody should ever entrust anybody's mental health to me. That's a bad idea. It's happened in the past. It hasn't ended well. Well, let's switch gears for a minute.
我的意思是，你知道，比如测试好的药物，最终是疫苗，对吧？有一种疫苗的想法。而没有得到太多关注的是任何形式的基于社区的反应，任何形式的行为反应，但这些都在受艾滋病影响最严重的社区中发展，草根，自下而上，特别是，你知道，纽约地区发生了很多事情，加利福尼亚和其他地方发生了很多事情，对吧？是的，男同性恋者健康危机，
moves to talking about the AIDS epidemic beginning in the 1980s, how did that change the questions that researchers were asking? Yeah, I think it's a really timely question to ask now in the middle of COVID as well. Sure. I think we'll, we might think about that relationship a bit later on as well. So, yeah, I looked for what psychologists were writing and what, in regard to HIV-AIDS. and when. And I think there's a real sea change in the middle of the 1980s on this. So when the President's Commission report comes out, the National Academy of Science puts out a report. And in the early part of the 1980s, what you can see happening in science is there's very much an approach that HIV-AIDS is going to be addressed first and foremost by a biological model. By a biological model,
像那样的人，他们，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的。我认为这些团体与当地政府的关系在不同的美国地方非常不同。我认为在加利福尼亚的部分地区比在纽约要快乐一点，如果我的历史没记错的话。但几乎没有。现在，有一小部分关于美国心理学家的特别章节大约在1984年，在那里你可以看到一些人
mean, you know, like testing good drugs and ultimately a vaccine, right? There's sort of an idea of a vaccine. And what's not getting a lot of attention is any kind of community-based response, any kind of behavioral response, but that's all sort of being developed in the communities, most hard hit by HIV, grassroots, bottom up, particularly, you know, an awful lot happens in the New York area, an awful lot happens in California and other places, right? Yeah, gay men's health crisis,
在20世纪70年代领导同性恋肯定倡议的人，特别是斯蒂芬·莫兰，他现在是一位咨询心理学家，在那里写道，这应该是一个问题。你知道，美国心理学会应该注意这一点。这种流行病有心理健康影响，这不是人们在关于艾滋病的国家话语中关注很多的事情，在某种程度上存在关于艾滋病的国家话语，
act up people like that who, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think those groups have different relationships with their local governments that are quite different in different American places. I think it's a little bit happier in parts of California
因为，当然，并没有太多。但我认为在这些报告在80年代出来之后，你开始看到心理学家可以看到，啊，这里有研究问题。啊，这里有可资助的研究问题。有一个非常大的《美国心理学家》特刊大约在1988年，我相当深入地研究了它，并谈论了很多。
that it is in New York, if I've got the history right. But there's very little. Now, there's a very, there's a short kind of special section of American psychologists about 1984, and there you can see that some people
在那里你可以看到各种各样的心理学家，社会心理学家、社区心理学家、生物心理学家都在说，这就是我们的领域可以为艾滋病做出贡献的地方。在书中，我冒险提出了这个想法。我很想看看听众对此有何看法，但我认为一旦这种情况发生，一旦艾滋病成为心理学家和美国心理学与美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）资助流等事物建立更富有成效关系的一种方式，我认为它采取了一些想法，即男同性恋和女同性恋者
who had been leading the kind of gay affirmative initiative in the 1970s, particularly Stephen Moran, who's now a counselling psychologist, writing there and saying, this should be an issue. You know, APA should take note of this. There's mental health implications of this epidemic, which is not something that people, has a lot of attention in the national discourse about HIV AIDS, to the extent that there is a national discourse about HIV AIDS,
只是有点边缘化的人。你知道，他们在20世纪70年代相当边缘化，但我认为他们在艾滋病那段可怕的时期被主流化了。他们显然是做出令人难以置信工作的协同行动者，第44分部，你知道，最初是女同性恋和男同性恋，但当然自那以后变得更加广泛，也在那种背景下形成了。但我认为如果我想到那些小团体之外，你知道，那些推动这一点的群体，我认为艾滋病改变了许多其他
because, of course, there isn't very much of one. But I think after these reports come out in the 80s, what you start to see then is psychologists can see, ah, there's research questions here. Ah, there's fundable research questions here. And there's a very large special issue of American psychologists about 1988, which I went through it in quite a bit of death and talked about quite a bit of death.
心理学家的想法，他们与特定的LGBT群体、项目或倡议没有任何特殊关系，并让这些人以一种不那么异性恋的方式思考。但你确实谈到了可资助的研究，我记得在那些日子里，没有多少资金，因为政府不想资助对同性恋者的研究，你不能询问人们的性取向，这使得进行所需的科学研究变得非常、非常具有挑战性。是的，确实。而且我认为我最近根据研究论文的内容分析写了更多内容。
And there you can see psychologists of all kinds of stripes, social psychologists, community psychologists, biological psychologists kind of saying, this is what our field could do to make a contribution to, HIV AIDS. In the book, I venture this idea. I am interested to see what listeners think about it, but I think once that happened, and once HIV AIDS became a way for psychologists and for psychology in the United States to have a more productive relationship with things like the NIMH funding streams and so on, I think it took some ideas that gay and lesbian people were
你知道，人们每隔一段时间就会这样做，你知道，回顾过去并说，你知道，我们在30年里问过关于女同性恋者的问题吗，对吧？人们写那些论文，对吧？如果你看看90年代中期关于LGBT人群健康的东西，就像大多数，我的意思是，绝大多数健康研究的发生是因为艾滋病资金。回到你最初关于性别歧视的问题，这就是为什么，尽管很多工作在很大程度上与女性主义对话并从中学习了很多，但实际上研究确实再次变得非常以男性为中心。你知道，它变得非常关注男性，因为它在很大程度上被艾滋病资金所主导。我认为在那之后，一旦那种情况开始消失，你知道，在蛋白酶抑制剂等药物在90年代中期变得可及，并且如果你能获得这些药物，艾滋病成为一种威胁较小、潜在威胁较小的疾病之后，
just people that were kind of a little bit marginal. You know, they were quite marginal in the 1970s, but I think they became mainstreamed over that horrific period of HIV AIDS. They were clearly concerted actors doing incredible work, Division 44, you know, which was initially lesbian and gay, but of course it's become much broader since, also took form in that context. But I think if I think beyond those kind of small. groups, right, of people who are sort of pushing that, I think HIV AIDS changed a lot of other
我认为你实际上看到了对LGBT人群的研究有所下降。我认为它在90年代达到顶峰。而且我认为它此后一直在某种程度上处于下降趋势。好吧，我想谈谈另一个研究不足的领域，即LGBTQ中的B，运动的一部分，它经常感到被忽视和被解雇。心理学是否对双性恋进行了任何重要的研究？如果是这样，发现是什么？
psychologists minds who had no particular relationship to a specific LGBT group or project or initiative and got those people thinking in a less heterosexual way. But you do talk about fundable research and what I remember from those days is that there wasn't a lot of funding because the government did not want to fund studies of gay people and you couldn't ask questions about people's sexual orientation, and it just made it really, really challenging to do the science that was needed. Yeah, it does. And I think I've recently written more based on content analyses of research papers.
我认为心理学有，而且我认为，哦，我希望我能记得是谁做的，因为我现在将容易受到那个人提到的同样事情的影响。我记得读过这篇关于双性恋的文章。是当有人说，双性恋就像《土拨鼠之日》，你知道吗？就像，它总是被遗忘，重置，重置，重置，重置，我记得我最近感觉非常老
You know, people every so often will do this, you know, look back and say, you know, what have we ever asked about lesbians in 30 years, right? People write those papers, right? And if you look at the stuff on health in the mid-90s and on LGBT population, it's like most, I mean, the vast majority of the health research has happened because of HIV-AIDS funding. And to get back to your original question about sexism, that's one of the reasons why, even though a lot of that work was very much in conversation with feminism and learning a lot from it, actually the research does become very undercentric again. You know, it becomes very much about men because it's very much dominated by HIV-AIDS funding. And I think after that time, once that sort of starts to go away, you know, after things like protease inhibitors become accessible in the mid-1990s and HIV-AIDS becomes a less threatened, potentially a less threatening illness if you can access those medications.
因为我正在和欧洲的一些博士研究员交谈，当我说是欧洲时，我确实是指到处，因为那些Zoom会议之一，你知道，我们在三个不同的时区。我正在怀念90年代在美国酷儿书店的经历。
I think you actually see a little bit of a decline in research on LGBT populations. And I think there's a peak of it kind of in the 90s. and I think it's been in somewhat of a decline sense. Well, I want to talk about another under-researched area, which is the B in the LGBTQ, a part of the movement, that often feels overlooked and dismissed. Has psychology done any significant research into bisexuality? And if so, what are the findings?
一种失落的经历，对吧？金，你的眼里也泛起了泪花。我记得看到玛乔丽·加伯，她在90年代初写了这本书《反之亦然》，全是关于双性恋的，就像，你知道，只是在旧金山的一家书店里翻阅那本书，
I think psychology has, and I think, oh, I wish I could remember who had done this, because I'm now going to be vulnerable to exactly the thing that that person mentioned. I remember reading this article about bisexuality. was when somebody said, bisexuality is like Groundhog Day, you know? It's like, it always kind of gets forgetting and reset and reset and reset and reset and I remember I was feeling very old recently
它真是太充满活力和令人兴奋了。而且，你知道，在我看来，十年后，当我来到英国时，我最终成为了英国心理学会女同性恋和男同性恋部门的主席。当时是现在。它被称为性心理学。我们做了很多工作，试图推动英国心理学会把像双性恋性别这样的词放在那个部门的名字里。
because I was talking to some PhD researchers here in Europe and when I say in Europe, I do mean kind of everywhere because one of those Zoom meetings, you know, we're in three different timesodes. And I was waxing nostalgic about the experience of being in queer bookstores in the States in the 1990s.
他们非常抵制她说，就像，没有关于双性恋的英国研究。我们说，好吧，没有人能和我们交谈，因为名字错了。所以，你知道，那些事情，我认为，发生了。然后多年后写金赛的书，只是，我想，人们并没有真正接受金赛作为一个双性恋人物，我认为，你知道吗？而且金赛并没有太多谈论性身份。他故意不谈论性身份。他谈论性行为。而且他的思维中有一些深层的原因。但我认为金赛量表的整个想法，这在某种程度上是人们从中学到的东西，
A lost experience, right? Kim, the tear coming to your eye as well here. And I remember seeing Marjorie Garber, who wrote this book, vice versa, in the early 1990s, which was all about bisexuality, like, you know, just kind of tossed through that book
是对他所说内容的一种修饰，即，你知道，很多很多人都有涉及，你知道，两种性别的人的性历史。我认为这是人们一次又一次、一次又一次、一次又一次发现的东西。就像，哦，看，这是一个大惊喜。你知道我的意思吗？你知道，就像，你知道，调查男同性恋者，他们中很多人和女性发生过性关系，调查，调查女性，调查，就像人们改变性取向标签。
in a bookstore in San Francisco, and it was just so vibrant and exciting. And, you know, it seems to me, Then like a decade later, when I came to the UK, I ended up being the chair of the lesbian and gay section of the VPS. It was at the time now. It's called the Psychology of Sexualities. And we did a lot of work kind of trying to push the British Psychological Society to put words like bisexual gender in the name of that section.
所以我认为确实有一些关于那个的《土拨鼠之日》，真的。我认为确实有一些关于那个的东西。我不确定关于双性恋的一个好而有意义的科学发现可能是什么。我的意思是，有研究人员，你知道，你可以谷歌一下，在21世纪初获得了很大关注，他们说，看，看，看，双性恋男人不存在。他们真的不存在。然后那些同样的研究人员获得了很大关注，
And they were very resistant to her saying like, like, there's no British research on bisexuality. We're like, well, nobody can talk to us because like the name. is wrong. So, you know, those kinds of things, I think, happen. And then kind of do writing the Kinsey book years later, just, I thought, like, people haven't really come to terms of Kinsey as a bisexual figure, I think, you know? And Kinsey doesn't talk about sexual identity very much. He deliberately doesn't talk about sexual identity. He talks about sexual behavior. And there's reasons that that are kind of deep in how his thinking is. But I think that whole idea of the Kinsey scale, which is kind of what people have kind of grabbed from that in a funny sort of way,
说，猜猜看，双性恋男人真的存在吗？你知道，所以我认为关于双性恋的主导叙事是说，这是关于双性恋的主导叙事，我们正在改变它。这与人们的亲身经历有什么关系？就像，它可能没有比，你知道，问同性恋是天生的还是后天的之类的东西多得多，你知道吗？好吧，让我们谈谈更近的历史。过去十年中最引人注目的权利收益之一是对同性伴侣婚姻平权的追求。
was a gloss on something that he was saying, which is, you know, like lots and lots and lots of people have sexual histories that involve, you know, people of two genders. And I think that's something that people find again and again and again and again and again. And it's like, oh, look, here's a big surprise. Do you know what I mean? You know, like, you know, serve gay men, lots of them had sex at women, surveys, service of women, surveys, like people change the sexual orientation label.
美国心理学会的心理学家深陷那场斗争，特别是通过我们的法庭之友计划，其中美国心理学会提交了关于心理学研究和婚姻平权开创性案件的摘要。心理学研究对这些法律胜利有多重要？我认为在美国背景下，它非常重要。而且美国背景也非常独特。我在其他地方工作时学到了这一点。我认为这是我想让美国听众知道的事情，特别是美国心理学家，是你根本不能做这种事情
So I think there is something, groundhog day about that, really. I think there is something about that. I'm not sure what a good and meaningful scientific finding about bisexuality might be. I mean, there are researchers who, you know, you can Google it, who got a lot of play early in the 21st century who's saying, look, look, look, bisexual men don't exist. They really don't. And then those same researchers got a lot of plays.
所以我认为这确实有一种“土拨鼠之日”的感觉，真的。我认为这其中有些门道。我不确定关于双性恋有什么好的、有意义的科学发现。我的意思是，有些研究人员，你知道的，你可以去谷歌搜索一下，他们在21世纪初非常活跃，他们说，看，看，看，双性恋男性根本不存在。他们真的不存在。然后同样是这些研究人员，后来又大肆宣传，
say, like, guess what, bisexual men really do exist? You know, so I think the dominant narrative about bisexuality is to say, here's the dominant narrative about bisexuality and we're changing it. And what relationship that has to people's lived experience? Like, it probably does not a lot more than, you know, is asking is homosexuality nature or nurture or something like that, you know? Well, let's talk about more recent history. One of the most striking rights gains in the last decade has been the quest for marriage equality for same-sex couples.
说，嘿，你猜怎么着，双性恋男性确实存在？你知道，所以我认为关于双性恋的主流叙事就是说，这就是关于双性恋的主流叙事，而我们正在改变它。这与人们的生活经历有什么关系呢？可能并没有比询问同性恋是先天还是后天之类的东西有更多关系，你知道吗？好吧，让我们谈谈更近的历史。过去十年中最引人注目的权利成就之一就是为同性伴侣争取婚姻平权。
Psychologists at APA were knee-deep in that fight, particularly through our amicus curiae program, in which APAs filed briefs on psychological research and seminal court cases on marriage equality. How important has psychological research been to these legal victories? I think in the U.S. context, it's very important. And the US context is also quite distinct. I have learned kind of working elsewhere. I think this is something I would want US listeners to know, particularly US psychologists, is you simply cannot do this kind of thing
美国心理学会（APA）的心理学家们深陷这场斗争，特别是通过我们的法庭之友项目，APA在婚姻平权的开创性案件中提交了关于心理学研究的简报。心理学研究对这些法律胜利有多重要？我认为在美国的背景下，它非常重要。而且美国的背景也相当独特。我在其他地方工作时学到了这一点。我认为这是我想让美国听众，特别是美国心理学家知道的事情，那就是你根本无法做这种事情
with amicus briefs and influence courts in other countries in the same kind of way. This is something culturally particularly that you do. It's incredibly important. It is a vulnerable history. In psychology, of course, it has a long history going back to Brown versus Board of Education, you know, gender discrimination cases more recently as well.
并以同样的方式影响其他国家的法院。这在文化上是你特别会做的事情。这极其重要。这是一段脆弱的历史。当然，在心理学领域，它有着悠久的历史，可以追溯到“布朗诉教育委员会案”，以及最近的性别歧视案件。
But certainly the APA starts, to lean into the amicus brief strategy a little bit more explicitly in the 1980s. And all of the amicus briefs that the APA has ever submitted are all online on the APA website. You can download them all and read them. I read lots of them writing the book. And what's striking, if you just look at it, is like the APA has gone to court to litigate, not to litigate, but to advise the court on the litigation of lesbian and gay rights more often than kind of anything else by a lot.
但可以肯定的是，美国心理学会（APA）在20世纪80年代开始更明确地倾向于“法庭之友”简报策略。APA提交过的所有“法庭之友”简报都可以在APA网站上在线查阅。你可以下载并阅读它们。我在写书时读了很多。如果你仔细观察，会发现令人震惊的是，APA为了诉讼而诉讼，不，不是为了诉讼，而是为了就女同性恋和男同性恋权利的诉讼向法院提供建议，这比其他任何事情都要多得多。
And, you know, a lot of that difference is to do with the marriage stuff in the 21st century. But that trajectory was already set in train by earlier stuff about sodomy laws, equal employment laws, parents' rights to custody of their children, and other things where APA had gone to court about lesbian and gay rights. So I think that is important. And I think it sets, one of my colleagues here said recently, it sort of sets a norm for a certain kind of research. that a prejudice researcher might desire, that, you know, it would be great if their research was used in something like that. The other thing I would kind of say is,
你知道，这种差异很大程度上与21世纪的婚姻问题有关。但这一轨迹早在之前关于鸡奸法、平等就业法、父母对子女的监护权以及APA就女同性恋和男同性恋权利诉诸法院的其他事情中就已经形成了。所以我认为这很重要。而且我认为它设定了——我的一位同事最近在这里说——它为某种研究设定了一种规范，偏见研究者可能会希望，你知道，如果他们的研究能用在这样的事情上会很棒。我想说的另一件事是，
you know, a lot of what people have done in that context is to do an Evelyn Hooker type project to say, look, actually, you know, relationships are not that different between same-sex and mixed-sex couples. And I think that's probably right. On the left wing, lots of people have fantasies that, you know, LGBT people will, you know,
你知道，人们在这种背景下所做的大部分工作都是做一个伊芙琳·胡克（Evelyn Hooker）式的项目，来说明，看，实际上，你知道，同性伴侣和异性伴侣之间的关系并没有那么大的不同。我认为这可能是对的。在左翼，很多人幻想，你知道，LGBT群体仅仅通过存在，就会……
dismantle lots of oppressive structures simply by being. And on the right wing, lots of people have fantasies that LGBT people will like dismantle of status quo structures simply by being. And we are neither the angels or monsters of these imaginations. We are ordinary people who, you know, eat breakfast and walk dogs and drive cars and, you know, worry about carbon footprints and things like that.
拆除许多压迫性结构。而在右翼，很多人幻想，LGBT群体仅仅通过存在，就会拆除现状结构。我们既不是这些想象中的天使，也不是怪物。我们是普通人，你知道，吃早餐、遛狗、开车，你知道，担心碳足迹之类的事情。
And so I think a lot of psychological research just does that. It kind of says, actually, things are not so different. So it was very, very obvious, I think, to a lot of people who were in any way involved in LGBT communities, that people had always been living in very long-term relationships where they were completely, you know, mutually interconnected in loving, lifelong ways with people of the same gender, forever, forever. And I think when the state woke up and said, what are we going to call these things to recognize? It would be hard to think of a better model for that than marriage.
所以我认为很多心理学研究只是做了这一点。它有点像是在说，实际上，事情并没有那么不同。所以，我认为对于任何以某种方式参与LGBT社区的人来说，非常非常明显的是，人们一直生活在非常长期的关系中，他们永远、永远地与同性别的人以充满爱、终身相伴的方式完全地、你知道，相互联系在一起。我认为当国家醒悟过来并说，我们该怎么称呼这些东西来承认它们呢？很难想到比婚姻更好的模式了。
So that was all very important. I think there is also always questions about whether that push around marriage, and it was quite strong. I remember being at the APA in 2010, and I just remember, like, you could have gone to a talk about equal marriage pretty much any hour of the day of the five days of that conference. I was like, okay. I think I want to go hang out with the history.
所以这一切都非常重要。我认为关于围绕婚姻的推动力是否——而且它确实非常强烈——也总是存在疑问。我记得2010年在APA，我只记得，在那次会议的五天里，你几乎可以在任何一小时去参加关于平等婚姻的讲座。我当时想，好吧。我想我还是去和历史待在一起吧。
I feel like I've been married at a little bit here. And I think, you know, people had good claims that there were other things that were happening that were of much, much more pressing concern to important LGBT communities that were being silenced by the marriage thing. So, yes, I thought to research very, very important. But I think also the question of how central marriage became in that platform of LGBT rights in general, and particularly within APA, is something. thing that I think it's important to think about what else was sort of going on in that context
我觉得我在这里已经有点“结婚”了。而且我认为，你知道，人们有充分的理由认为，还有其他事情正在发生，这些事情对重要的LGBT社区来说更为紧迫，却被婚姻问题所掩盖。所以，是的，我认为研究非常非常重要。但我认为，婚姻在LGBT权利平台中，特别是在APA内部变得如此核心的问题，也是一件值得思考的事情，即在那种背景下还有什么在发生，
as well and what might have got the same attention. So if, as you were saying, the situation in the U.S. is distinct because of our Supreme Court, the way that we're structured and the court cases have been really important, but not so much in other countries, is the research still useful in other countries that are grappling with the same question around marriage equality? Some of us. But I think ultimately what you would want is you would want these rights to be given not on the basis of convincing people by psychological research.
以及什么可能得到了同样的关注。所以，正如你所说，美国的局势因为最高法院而与众不同，我们的结构方式和法院案件确实非常重要，但在其他国家却并非如此，那么这项研究对于其他正在努力解决婚姻平等问题的国家还有用吗？有些有用。但我认为最终你想要的是，这些权利的给予不应基于用心理学研究去说服人们。
Do you know? I think that only takes you so far. What's the other argument? That is the right thing to do? That it's just... That is the right thing to do. That's the right thing to do. So, I mean, two people who are really important in this history are a lesbian couple here in Britain
你知道吗？我认为这只能带你走这么远。另一个论点是什么？那是正确的事情？那只是……那是正确的事情。那是正确的事情。所以，我的意思是，在这个历史中非常重要的两个人是英国的一对女同性恋伴侣，
called Sue Wilkinson and Celia Kittinger, who did... incredibly important work, set up the journal Feminism and Psychology, set up the lesbian and gay section of the British Psychological Society, really important, qualitative research on women's health and lesbian identity and a thousand other things. And they, I mean, you can read their story for yourself. If you look at the Psychology's Feminist Voices website, their oral history is there and they talk about this. But they took a case to the the Supreme Court here in the UK with two other couples. They had a Canadian marriage at the time
名叫苏·威尔金森（Sue Wilkinson）和西莉亚·基廷格（Celia Kittinger），她们做了……极其重要的工作，创办了《女性主义与心理学》杂志，建立了英国心理学会的女同性恋和男同性恋分会，对女性健康、女同性恋身份和其他一千件事进行了非常重要的定性研究。而且她们，我的意思是，你可以自己读她们的故事。如果你查看“心理学的女性主义声音”网站，她们的口述历史就在那里，她们谈到了这一点。但她们和另外两对夫妇一起向英国最高法院提起诉讼。她们当时在加拿大结婚，
when they wanted to have recognized in the UK. Sue had been living in Canada for a while. And they lost their case and had to pay their courts. You know, they had to pay the expenses of that, which well entered the thousands. And, you know, that was like, I think, maybe about 2006 or so. And the judgment given at that point
她们希望在英国得到承认。苏在加拿大住过一段时间。她们输掉了官司，不得不支付诉讼费。你知道，她们不得不支付那笔费用，这可是数千英镑。而且，你知道，那大概是在2006年左右。当时给出的判决
in time was, you know, just simply, it's tradition that marriage is a man and a woman. And now, look, you know, where things are. So, you know, so I think there are, you'd want to win that argument on the ground. I mean, the other place that's really interesting is Ireland here. I could linger on this story for a while. I wasn't in Ireland the day of this vote. And because I live overseas, I don't have a vote in Ireland for good reasons. But, you know, the day that this marriage referendum,
是，你知道，很简单，婚姻是一男一女的传统。现在，看，你知道，事情发展到什么地步了。所以，你知道，所以我认为有，你会想在实地上赢得那个论点。我的意思是，另一个非常有趣的地方是这里的爱尔兰。我可以在这个故事上徘徊一会儿。投票那天我不在爱尔兰。因为我住在海外，出于正当理由，我在爱尔兰没有投票权。但是，你知道，这次婚姻公投的那天，
went down. It was kind of like, I got all of these sort of, like, emails and messages from people I hadn't heard from in years, like, years. I mean, decades. People I, like, a guy I shared a flat with in California, like 20 years earlier, he completely lost contact with, which he emailed me from Hawaii. Like, you're a very senior researcher in Europe who I greatly admire, like, email, like, it was like that, when Ireland voted, you know, it's like, everybody wants to touch an Irish gay person, you know? I was the available Irish gay person in some people's network and they wanted to. That was lovely.
结果出来了。就像是，我收到了所有这些，你知道，来自多年没联系的人的电子邮件和信息，真的是多年。我的意思是几十年。人们，比如我在加州合租过房子的一个人，20年前，完全失去了联系，他从夏威夷给我发了邮件。就像，你是一位我非常钦佩的欧洲资深研究员，发邮件，就像，当爱尔兰投票时，你知道，就像，每个人都想接触一个爱尔兰同性恋者，你知道吗？我是某些人网络中现成的爱尔兰同性恋者，他们想接触。那很可爱。
You know, that was so amazing. But, you know, I mean, what happened psychologically in Ireland was very interesting. And I think it was informed by some of the things that happened in the US, particularly in California. And the actress in Ireland had a very sustained campaign of personally touching every person in the country. you know, they knocked on doors. Everybody had a face-to-face conversation. And I think as a result, everybody thought deeply about this issue. And that's a very different kind of thinking from putting off some research and saying,
你知道，那太棒了。但是，你知道，我的意思是，爱尔兰在心理上发生的事情非常有趣。我认为它受到了一些在美国，特别是在加州发生的事情的影响。爱尔兰的活动人士进行了一场非常持续的运动，亲自接触了全国的每一个人。你知道，他们敲门。每个人都进行了面对面的交谈。我认为结果是，每个人都深入思考了这个问题。这与抛出一些研究并说，
ha ha, your side is wrong, our side is right, this group is similar or this group is different, which is a mode of argument you can do with psychological research, which is very common in the US. But I think what they did in Ireland was really different. and they engage people in a different kind of thinking. It was longer. It was harder. And it made sense to do it that way. And, you know, in Ireland, that worked.
哈哈，你们那边错了，我们这边对了，这个群体相似或那个群体不同，这是一种可以用心理学研究进行的论证模式，这在美国非常普遍，是完全不同的思考方式。但我认为他们在爱尔兰所做的事情真的不同。他们让人们参与了一种不同的思考。它更长。它更难。而且那样做是有道理的。而且，你知道，在爱尔兰，这奏效了。
And then I think one of the countries in the former Yugoslavia, I think it was Slovenia, at the same year, had a marriage referendum as well, and it went against them, again, by a two-thirds majority. And they didn't do that there, if I understand it rightly. You know, they didn't get into rural community. They didn't have that kind of penetration. So I think what is real, James? what is lasting change, I think it very often does involve deep conversations rather than, here's my research, now I've proved you wrong. Like that has a place in argumentation,
然后我认为前南斯拉夫的一个国家，我想是斯洛文尼亚，在同一年也进行了婚姻公投，结果违背了他们的意愿，再次以三分之二的多数票否决了。如果我没理解错的话，他们没有在那里那样做。你知道，他们没有深入农村社区。他们没有那种渗透力。所以我认为什么是真实的，詹姆斯？什么是持久的改变，我认为它通常确实涉及深入的对话，而不是，“这是我的研究，现在我证明你错了”。这在论证中有一席之地，
it's a place in conversation, but it's not the whole of it. And I think psychologists who do that kind of research need to recognize it's not the whole of it. Right, right. And certainly we have that history here in the US. I mean, where the courts have occasionally been ahead of where the populace is, for example, Brown versus Board of Education. You know, we didn't, I mean, we're still fighting that war. You know, the racism in our country is quite pervasive. And you can't just change people's hearts and minds because a court says that this is what you need to do. Yeah. So that's an excellent point. I wanted to talk about your other work, your experimental research. I know one of your recent papers on auditory Gaydar found that people may discriminate
它在对话中有一席之地，但它不是全部。我认为做这类研究的心理学家需要认识到它不是全部。对，对。当然，我们在美国也有那段历史。我的意思是，法院有时领先于民众，例如“布朗诉教育委员会案”。你知道，我们没有，我的意思是，我们仍在打那场战争。你知道，我们国家的种族主义非常普遍。你不能仅仅因为法院说这是你需要做的，就改变人们的心和思想。是的。所以这是一个极好的观点。我想谈谈你的其他工作，你的实验研究。我知道你最近关于听觉“Gaydar”（同性恋雷达）的一篇论文发现，人们在做招聘决定时可能会歧视
against quote, unquote, lesbian-sounding women and gay-sounding men when they're making hiring decisions. Can you talk about that research a little bit? Yeah, I just a massive shout out to Fabio Fasoli, who is the real genius in this. Fabio is an Italian psychologist who works at the University of Surrey, who is published extensively on auditory Gaydar and the kinds of discrimination it can bring around. He worked as a postdoc fellow with me for two years in Surrey, and it was in that context that we did that research. So Gaydar is very often studied in psychology. I get there is when you kind of, you know, make an inference about somebody's sexual orientation, usually the inference that like, oh, I no longer assume that person is straight
所谓的“听起来像女同性恋”的女性和“听起来像男同性恋”的男性。你能谈谈那项研究吗？是的，我只想向法比奥·法索利（Fabio Fasoli）大声致敬，他是这方面的真正天才。法比奥是一位在萨里大学工作的意大利心理学家，他在听觉“Gaydar”以及它可能带来的各种歧视方面发表了大量文章。他在萨里和我一起做了两年的博士后研究员，正是在这种背景下，我们做了那项研究。所以“Gaydar”在心理学中经常被研究。当你，你知道，对某人的性取向做出推断时，通常是那种推断，比如，哦，我不再假设那个人是异性恋，
because of something about them. It can be an aspect of their physical appearance or something about the way they move or in our studies something about the way that they speak. So in these studies, people listen to very, very short extracts of talk, which were said to be from interviews where people were being interviewed for leadership positions in various roles. And they listened to voices that with pre-tests, we could tell, people thought either sounded gay or lesbian or sounded like straight women or men. And as in other studies, we found a discrimination effect so that people who sounded gay or lesbian were less likely to be hired for those roles
因为关于他们的某些东西。它可以是他们外表的一个方面，或者是他们移动方式的某些东西，或者在我们的研究中，是他们说话方式的某些东西。所以在这些研究中，人们听取了非常非常简短的谈话片段，据说来自人们在各种角色中被面试领导职位的面试。他们听到的声音，通过预测试，我们可以看出，人们认为听起来像男同性恋或女同性恋，或者听起来像异性恋女性或男性。正如在其他研究中一样，我们发现了歧视效应，因此听起来像男同性恋或女同性恋的人被聘用担任这些角色的可能性较小，
and judged to be less suitable for them as well. One of the things that was most surprising in those studies, and this was a consistent finding across three experiments was that the stronger pattern of discrimination was in regard to the women targets. So there was much stronger discrimination against a woman who sounded lesbian compared to a woman who sounded straight
而且也被认为不太适合这些角色。在这些研究中最令人惊讶的事情之一，而且这是三个实验中一致的发现，是歧视模式在女性目标方面更强。因此，与听起来像异性恋的女性相比，对听起来像女同性恋的女性的歧视要强烈得多，
than against a man who sounded gay, then against a man who sounded straight. And that's an on-finding because we looked at this the other way. So when Fabio has asked gay and straight, women and men, how much do you think your voice communicate your sexual orientation? Like, men think that much more than women do? By the way, when you ask the question, how much do you want your voice to communicate your sexual orientation? The group that says they really want
而对听起来像男同性恋的男性与听起来像异性恋的男性相比，歧视则没那么强。这是一个非预期的发现，因为我们从另一个角度看了这个问题。所以当法比奥问男同性恋和异性恋的女性和男性，你认为你的声音在多大程度上传达了你的性取向时？男性认为这比女性多得多。顺便说一句，当你问这个问题，你多大程度上希望你的声音传达你的性取向时？那个说他们真的希望
that is straight men, right? That's the group that really wants their voice to communicate sexual orientation. We've also, like, done studies where we've asked lesbian and gay men, like, how much do you kind of fear this sort of discrimination? You know, happening to you, and in that study, you know, gay men fear it more than lesbian. do and so on. So it's sort of interesting, like the social representation of Gator is that it's something that happens to men. But in this study, it was actually stronger among women. And in most of the discrimination studies, actually, you don't see it just happening to men. You tend to see it happening to both men and women. So, so yeah, we are working on that. We are working on two more
那样的群体是异性恋男性，对吧？那是真正希望他们的声音传达性取向的群体。我们还做过研究，询问女同性恋和男同性恋男性，你多大程度上担心这种歧视？你知道，发生在你身上，在那项研究中，你知道，男同性恋比女同性恋更担心，等等。所以这很有趣，就像“Gaydar”的社会表征是它发生在男性身上。但在本研究中，它实际上在女性中更强。而且在大多数歧视研究中，实际上，你不仅看到它发生在男性身上。你往往会看到它同时发生在男性和女性身上。所以，所以是的，我们正在研究那个。我们正在研究另外两篇
papers to figure out that conundrum, I have to say. And we have some partial answers to it. But let's see if the field thinks they're worthy of publishing. Yeah, I mean, that does sound like a surprising finding to me largely because, and we get back to the question of sexism and sex roles in society, because being masculine is valued. Yeah. And if a woman comes off as being more, quote, masculine and potentially more gay, then you would think that that would be valued.
论文来弄清楚那个难题，我必须说。我们对它有一些部分的答案。但让我们看看该领域是否认为它们值得发表。是的，我的意思是，这对我来说确实听起来是一个令人惊讶的发现，主要是因为，我们回到社会中的性别歧视和性别角色问题，因为男性气质受到重视。是的。如果一个女性表现得更“男性化”且可能更像同性恋，那么你会认为这会受到重视。
And instead, what you're finding is something quite different. Yeah, no, absolutely. Thank you for coming back to it. This is people have this question, particularly around something like leadership roles in companies, which was the context here. So that's a context where people supposedly imagine those people as being men by default and value masculine attributes, overvalue masculine attributes, one could easily say. And so you might think that, yeah, stereotyping might go in a lesbian's favour in less. No, we did measure in those studies how much do you think these people are masculine or, feminine and you do get some stereotyping effect, but the lesbian is not getting any boost
相反，你发现的是完全不同的东西。是的，不，绝对是。谢谢你回到这一点。这是人们有的问题，特别是在公司领导角色之类的事情上，这就是这里的背景。所以这是一个人们默认想象那些人是男性，并重视男性属性，甚至可以说过度重视男性属性的背景。所以你可能会认为，是的，刻板印象可能会对女同性恋有利。不，我们在那些研究中确实测量了你认为这些人有多男性化或女性化，你确实得到了一些刻板印象效应，但女同性恋并没有从中得到任何提升。
out of that. What's happening is that she is seen as less competent, and that seems to be an inference from her perceived sexual orientation. That's the more consistent pattern that explains the discrimination across those studies. So I think a point here, and I think this is kind of difficult for some people maybe to wrap your head around, is that yes, there is this kind of gendery kind of stereotyping around gay and lesbian people that happens all the time. Yeah, that's, that's, that's not difficult to capture an experiment. But it's also the case that sexual orientation is still a status variable, right? It's still a marker of your status, a marker of your higher status to be straight. And that's why we kind of thought, actually, I think status needs to be thought about
发生的事情是她被认为能力较差，这似乎是从她被感知的性取向中得出的推论。这是在这些研究中解释歧视的一致模式。所以我认为这里的一点，而且我认为这对某些人来说可能很难理解，是是的，确实存在这种围绕男同性恋和女同性恋的性别刻板印象，这种事情一直在发生。是的，那，那，那在实验中并不难捕捉。但同样的情况是，性取向仍然是一个地位变量，对吧？它仍然是你地位的标志，是异性恋者地位更高的标志。这就是为什么我们认为，实际上，我认为当我们思考如果人们是女同性恋和男同性恋，或者即使他们听起来像女同性恋或男同性恋，他们可能会遇到的歧视景观是什么时，地位也需要被考虑
in this equation as well when we think about what is the landscape of discrimination that people might encounter if they are lesbian and gay, or even if they sound lesbian or gay, that's an important distinction to make and go for leadership positions. And of course, these days, I mean, this podcast is a good example. Like, there's some people that you meet only by hearing their voice, you know. And, you know, since COVID, there's a lot more of this kind of digitally mediated communication as well. So how people sound can make a big difference. Well, I want to wrap up with a question that takes us back to your book for a moment, because you ended it by writing that it's important for all psychologists to have some knowledge of the recent
在这个等式中，这是一个重要的区别，去争取领导职位。当然，这些天，我的意思是，这个播客就是一个很好的例子。就像，有些人你只能通过听到他们的声音来认识，你知道。而且，你知道，自COVID以来，这种数字化中介的交流也多了很多。所以人们听起来如何会产生很大的不同。好吧，我想用一个带我们回到你的书的问题来结束，因为你在结尾写道，所有心理学家都具备一些关于LGBT心理学近期历史的知识是很重要的，
history of LGBT psychology and that the field offers something of what you call generalizable usefulness beyond gay men and lesbians to whom it initially applied. What can psychology, what can the rest of psychology learn from the history of LGBT psychology? I'm glad you picked up on that point. And I'm going to answer it by sort of thinking about two linguistic terms that are now really common. So one is coming out. Okay. I think it would be really hard to to make an argument that coming out as a way of thinking about having a relationship between yourself and shame, it originates anywhere else other than in LGBT culture. That would be a little bit tricky to do. That particular understanding of it. And you know, you can come out as just about
而且该领域提供了一些你所说的“可推广的有用性”，超出了它最初适用的男同性恋和女同性恋。心理学，心理学的其余部分能从LGBT心理学的历史中学到什么？我很高兴你提到了这一点。我将通过思考两个现在非常常见的语言术语来回答它。一个是“出柜”（coming out）。好吧，我认为很难论证“出柜”作为一种思考你与羞耻感之间关系的方式，起源于LGBT文化之外的任何地方。那样做会有点棘手。那种特定的理解。而且你知道，你现在几乎可以对任何事情“出柜”，对吧？你知道，我可以对这样一个事实“出柜”，比如，我重新加入了我们当地的国际象棋俱乐部，因为我看了《女王的棋局》。这有点丢人，但我知道我的社区在那里支持我。你知道，我可以对这样一个事实“出柜”，即我对20世纪70年代初那种特别令人反感的、你知道，前卫摇滚、英国老爸风格的东西有品味，这对大多数人来说是无法聆听的，你知道，我可以听很长时间像亨利·考（Henry Cow）和深红之王（King Crimson）这样的东西。那有点丢人。那是完全不酷的音乐，对吧？但我只是不在这个播客上冒险说出来，我希望我能活着讲出来。所以你几乎可以对任何事情“出柜”。而且那个，但那种思考方式，那种思考方式，那种思考方式，
anything now, right? You know, so I could come out about the fact that, like, I have rejoined our local chess club because I've seen Queen's Gambit. It's a little bit shameful, but I know my community is there to affirm me. You know, I could come out about the fact that I have a taste in particularly distasteful, you know, prog rock, British dad stuff from the early 1970s that's unlistnable for most people, you know, I can listen to things like, you know, Henry Cow and King Crimson for a long time. That's a little bit shameful. It's utterly uncool music, right? But I just don't go to venture that on this podcast and I hope I live to tell the tell. So you can come out about just about anything. And that, but that way of thinking, that way of thinking, that way of thinking,
关于社会与心灵、披露与秘密之间的关系，很难争辩说那不是来自LGBT文化及其起源。我认为那是那些礼物之一，对吧？另一个，我认为，是后缀“-phobia”（恐惧症），用来描述一种非理性的偏见。我认为“恐同症”（homophobia）可能起源于你开始的地方，大约在纽约石墙起义的时候。这当然是乔治·温伯格（George Weinberg）在他1973年的书中提到的地方，等等。这些天，你可以用它来描述任何东西。你知道，你可以描述“恐胖症”（fat phobia）。
about the relationship between society and the psyche, disclosure and secrecy, it would be hard to argue that that is not coming from LGBT culture and its origin. And I think that's one of those gifts, right? The other one, I think, is the suffix a phobia, right, to describe an irrational kind of prejudice. And homophobia, I think, originates probably back where you started around the time of the Stonewall uprising in New York. And that's certainly where George Weinberg picks it up in his 1973 book and so on. These days, you can use that to describe anything. You know, you can describe fat phobia.
你可以描述“恐跨症”（transphobia）。你可以描述“恐自闭症”（autism phobia）。我在双性人世界的一些朋友想谈论“恐双性人症”（intersex phobia），你知道？你可以把它应用到任何事情上。所以，你知道，我甚至听过弗拉基米尔·普京（Vladimir Putin）谈论“恐俄症”（Russiaphobia），你知道？当我这样做时，我认为那很可爱。
You can describe transphobia. You can describe an autism phobia. Some of my friends in the intersex world want to talk about intersex phobia, you know? And you can apply it to anything. So, you know, I've even heard Vladimir Putin, you know, talk about Russiaphobia, you know? And when I do that, I think that's lovely.
弗拉基米尔·普京欠LGBT运动一笔知识债。那不是很可爱吗？你知道，特朗普可能也谈论过某种“恐美症”（American phobia）。同样，可爱。你知道，谢谢你承认那种知识，唐纳德。而且，你知道，所以当你听到这些事情时，我认为这是另一种用于思考事物的语言或概念礼物。对我们的偏见可能完全是非理性的。
Vladimir Putin owes an intellectual debt to LGBT movements. Isn't that all quite lovely? You know, Trump probably talked about some kinds of American phobia as well. Again, lovely. You know, thank you for acknowledging that intellectual, that Donald. And, you know, so when you hear these things, I think this is another kind of linguistic or conceptual gift for thinking about things. That the prejudice against us just might be completely irrational.
因为我说我们既不是怪物也不是天使，但我们是，你知道，吃早餐、遛狗、下棋和听烂音乐的普通人。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我们，哈格蒂博士。和你交谈真是太愉快了，而且非常有趣。我希望我们已经教给我们的听众一些他们不知道的关于LGBT心理学历史的事情。非常感谢。这是一种快乐。你可以在www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，
Because I say we're neither monsters or angels, but we're sort of, you know, ordinary people who eat breakfast and walk dogs and play chess and listen to bad music. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Haggerty. It's been a real pleasure talking to you and really interesting. I hope that we've taught our listeners a few things about the history of LGBT psychology that they didn't know. Thank you so much. It's been a joy. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple,
Stitcher，或者任何你获取播客的地方。而且请，如果可以的话，给我们留个评论。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Kondyenne）。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please, if you can, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Stitcher，或者任何你收听播客的地方。如果可以的话，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Winerman制作。我们的音频编辑是Chris Kondyenne。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。